لا اله الا الله الوصيه الاخيره ظنا منه
انه مفارق يا رب انا اسف على كل شيء يعرف
ابي انت كنت عايش اسمعي شوي ساميه ابي اذا
كنت عايش شايف هذا الفيديو اعيش حياتك
عايش عيش حياتكم صلوا صلوا صلوا تلك
الوصيه لم تصل لا للابي ولا الاخ ولا
الاخرين
نجا احمد وبقيت وصيته معلقه مات من يحبهم
وفي ذاكرته صور كثيره لكن بالبيت صار
الزلزال اول حاولنا نجتمع عند الباب
ونفتحه لكن ما فتح اجز زلزال تاني وانا
الحمد لله رب العالمين فضل رب العالمين
احسنت اطلع لفوق واجى الانقاذ ساعدني توفى
لي عشر اشخاص ونحن حاليا بتركيا 15 بابي
انه خمسه عشر بعشر عشر ساعات قضاها احمد
تحت الانقاض وعشره ماتوا من اهله واقاربه
ذاك جرح مفتوح وتلك مصيبه يداويها الصبر
ومفاتيح فرج كهذا الرجل استقبل احمد في
بيته مع خاله باستعمل حيا الله انسان مو
بس انا كل انسان مو متضرر بيته لازم
يستقبل كل انسان منضرب معلش انا
صعب بس اني اصعب